good morning Hank it's Tuesday old
school blog but this video where I talk
about stuff I care about with people I
care about today's videos like the
modern pentathlon it comes to you in
five parts part 1 when the Faulkner
stars first came out people were always
like is hazel Esther I can tell that
hazel is Esther hazel is Esther isn't
she and breath it's true that Esther was
a huge inspiration for The Fault in Our
Stars I could never have written it if I
had known her by the way new
nerdfighters Esther Earl was a
nerdfighter who died in 2010 of cancer
when she was 16 and she was also a
friend of mine and just a generally
awesome person but this book is not
about her Esther story doesn't belong to
me it belongs to her and to her family
but in wonderful news Hank that story is
going to be told Esther was a brilliant
writer and this book cover not final
comes out in January 2014 it's gonna
have her Diaries and fiction that she
wrote and letters that she wrote and
stuff from her parents and an
introduction by me sorry about the
massive hole in my mouth by the way I'm
open now it fixed by next Tuesday this
book is going to be esther story and
it's amazing and i'm so happy that it is
going to be a thing in the world and you
can pre-order it now link in the
doobly-doo Bart dude the groundhog so
hank here in our Indianapolis office we
have a groundhog we actually call him
YouTube because he spends a lot of time
inside he's easily distracted and he
knew who Hank and John were before it
was cool anyway YouTube's at a quiet
winter just eating grass but now it is
spring which means that the Canadian
geese have returned from Canada Mexico
what am i wildlife biologist anyway they
have returned and there is one
particularly aggressive Canadian goose
with whom YouTube is locked in a battle
for supremacy thank this quiet Battle of
I shall protect my whole well I shall
stand here and stare at you menacingly
has been going on for weeks and it's
impossible to get any work done so if my
new book doesn't come out till like 2018
you know why part 3 the tiffy OS movie
so ink it seems increasingly likely
although it's still definitely not
certain that there will actually be a
movie adaptation of my book The Fault in
Our Stars I know this makes
nerdfighteria nervous and believe me it
makes me nervous too but the director
Josh Boone is a brilliant guy who really
deeply understands the book his first
movie stuck in love doesn't come out
until June but it is really great also
they just cast shailene woodley as a
hazel shailene woodley has like a Golden
Globe nomination and a special jury
award from Sundance for the spectacular
now and she's a brilliant actress and
she is also a huge fan of the book like
a real fan Hank
sent me a letter before any of this
stuff happened so Hank you're about to
hear me say the most positive thing I
have ever said about Hollywood I think
we should be cautiously optimistic my
life is a little bit weird at the moment
but it will go back to being normal soon
part 4 oh wait it's not going back to
being normal because I'm about to have a
human child Sarah just pointed out that
in fact I'm not going to have it that's
true but I am going to be the father of
it when that happens May June I will be
going on a four or possibly five week
paternity leave from blog brothers and
also everything else except probably
tumblr I wish I knew how to quit you
tumblr but fear not Hank during my
absence you'll be entertained by a
series of guest John's including the
likes of Hannah Hart and grace Helbig
and also someone from nerdfighteria who
is currently watching this video which
reminds me part 5 we are bringing back
nerd factor nerd factors a contest idea
we stole from Michael Buckley basically
nerdfighters you should make your
favorite video only one of your videos a
video response to this video then we
will watch all of the many video
responses and pick our favorites as the
winners of nerd factor those videos and
your channels will be featured in a vlog
brothers video in the future and one of
you will be one of the paternity leave
guests dose if you're willing to do it
hank dftba i'll see you on Friday oh how
trying to turn off the camera for god
sakes